[Music]
I'm John I'm a private investigator here
in Los Angeles and today I have to
deduce which of these subjects is the
lone wolf the single person hello we
please join me here what's your name
Spencer do people tell you look like
Sarah Paulson yeah is that annoying no
yeah it gets repetitive it's very
complimentary ya think but when you hear
it a bunch like maybe like loses its
luster or something yeah I used to tell
people she was my aunt so you're a liar
there you go Spencer you said with an S
not a C in the middle mm-hmm okay no it
doesn't start with a seat what's the
vowel situation ease by dealing with
easier okay no eyes Oro's great it's not
Spence or
I feel like we're vibing a little bit
here aren't we yeah yeah wonder how that
makes anybody else back there feel were
you from Boston well part 30 minutes
south of Boston south yeah what's in the
town situate situate yeah okay and a
santa see where'd you go to college New
York oh yeah Rose Hill or Lincoln
Center's Hill okay let's say what do you
do um I'm our concierge here we've met a
few times I've signed you in multiple
times Oh at the front desk yeah yeah
yeah well I tend not to talk to you know
below-the-line people so concierge okay
so you work over there in the main
building I guess
all right services okay got you how long
have you lived in Los Angeles three
years where do you live now West
Hollywood it's like on the line between
West Hollywood and Hollywood I would
have said two minutes away but I don't
want people to know where I live
well I would say West Hollywood is more
specific than two minutes away that's
fair okay will you come and join me
thanks what's your name Seth Seth SCT
thank you were you from word I was like
born or where do I currently live
more the former where were you born
where did you grow up where are you from
New Jersey New Jersey well part Bergen
County like northeast it's like five
minutes south of like upstate border and
then when that's like north okay so for
an outsider like me general New York
municipal area kind of New York City
yeah yeah I mean within tri-state area
okay traicee area all right gotcha hold
you third okay sure yeah well my
birthday's coming up so why is baiting
next week Monday November
all right where do you live Chicago what
okay what are you doing here it isn't my
brother okay we're in Chicago the
Ukrainian Village
what's down yeah okay what do you do out
there digital advertising through a
little mention now so you know the
intersection of Chicago and Damon that
huh yeah okay
what business is on the northeast corner
of that intersection I think it is the
Greek restaurant but North East I know
there's a coffee shop and then there's a
Greek restaurant and there's a gas
station but I don't know that northeast
one uh did you go to autograph yep where
you long University Ilan yep gotcha
North Carolina yeah yeah you guys dating
pretty single it's a sad story so yes
but yeah do you want to do
very small pupils do pupils are pretty
small it's kind of come bad of this
batch predate anybody nope you got any
of the apps um I did but I'm more
old-school I like to meet people at bars
which which apps were you on are you
familiar with I was on hinge and Bumble
and you don't even know what the hell
that is
and what no good yeah kinda you just
going through the motions I feel like
it's all on the apps now are you finding
like-minded individuals yeah yeah in
Chicago yeah where's your brother Louv
Neal is here yeah where you used to live
in Culver City but I know where it is
now are you on the apps mm-hmm which
ones hinge so what does hinge what's the
hook Bumble girls have to reach out
first right gives you access to what
gives you prompts that you have to
answer like mine says where would you
find at a party and my answer is with
the dog all right how do you 26 mm-hm
what'd you do for fun I mostly just say
it although watch what's your favorite
movie Ferris Bueller's Day Off no man
what's your favorite 21st century movie
guardians the galaxy all of them mm-hmm
what's your favorite movie I'd say
kingpin nice okay all right I think I
got enough for now thanks for your time
will you join me please tell me your
name
I said essence were you from feet yeah
yes I didn't do that
no that's no you didn't there's a little
curl on the bottom of the sea oh okay
never seen that I'll just make it
clearer just for you um were you from
I'm from Georgia okay you live out here
now no where do you live Jersey how old
are you okay I'm 32 did you go to
undergrad college where'd you go to
college I went to undergrad at Albany
State and Georgia and grad and SUNY
Albany in New York big on the albany's I
guess that's just kind of how you know
life panned out what do you do I work
here at BuzzFeed doing what I'm the
beauty director okay do they have a
whole Beauty like a category of videos
and stuff like that okay videos and
editorial content so what do you do do
you edit those articles and sometimes
sometimes I edit I do mostly like big
features so like celebrity interviews on
the editorial side sometimes I'm in
videos like this which have nothing to
do with beauty at all do you conduct
those interviews yeah you must be very
comfortable since you're used to dealing
with very popular very likeable kind of
like famous people right exactly right
oh are you saying that's you're
comparing yourself to them obviously
yeah yeah which I yeah I knew that
honestly okay totally
will you come join me please join us
what's your name Austin Austin hey
Austin
and where are you from Torrance ah and
what do you do I am a case assistant at
a law firm and how long have you guys
been dating we haven't because I'm safe
[Music]
one's assembly on a date mmm last year
how'd it go it was okay
what am I even trying to do find out
who's single how do you Austin Toni
thing okay
essence thank you for your time I think
I'm done for now I might need you back
later okay
will you come join me here Thanks tell
me your name I'm Jana Jana yes two ends
everybody's spelling today I guess I
appreciate it it's nice where are you
from I am from San Bernardino California
okay
where do you live now I live in Los
Angeles okay what neighborhood south of
k-town Crenshaw area what do you do I
work on the social team at BuzzFeed well
what do you do day-to-day are you in
charge of deciding when to release the
videos okay I manage publishing and I
manage content strategy okay
anyway you datin no no Halloween I'm 25
so you ought to say something I mean I
been seeing people but I'm still single
so what does that mean seeing people I
recently went out with my housemates
coworker that was fun but I didn't
really I didn't really vibe with him
okay and then I had a crush on my
housemates best friend but I really
don't know what that was your sex life
it's it's a-you know you get you get
people here and there that are like
sometimes I'm like yeah but sometimes
I'm like no and then I just ghost them
brutal yeah Wow yeah I mean gotta say
what you got to say yeah I guess so I
guess all's fair I guess it's a the Wild
West out there so so when's the last
date you went on the last day I went on
was last weekend okay what you what you
folks do I went to see what was what was
the name
that movie oh it went to see parasite
okay yeah all right we're at at the
ArcLight I have so many questions about
this date but I don't think it matters
because I think the whole thing is a lie
okay thank you Jana thank you awesome
thank you so four of these people make
up two couples
[Music]
all right this is tough
[Music]
you know cuz you know I'd like you know
I'd like to be likeable you know I'd
like to you know it's not like
completely inappropriate to ask about
someone's you know like orientation or
like who they like to date but like it
also seems a little intrusive you know
then again I needed like details of
Seth's sex life so alright I have my
feelings I have my hunches here's the
deal I think I think Janna and Austin
are dating they've been out of my
thought process for a while
that obviously narrows things down Seth
is the answer to my investigation here I
think Seth is straight which means he's
dating either essence or Spencer can't
rule out the fact that maybe Spencer in
essence are dating and Seth is the
single one but says he lives in Chicago
essence says she lives in New York
maybe that's partially true you can't
really trust anybody
they're of similar ages she's from
Georgia he went to college in Georgia
again this is what they tell me she went
to she lives in Jersey he's familiar
with New Jersey I think maybe he went to
school out there used to live there grew
up there I think doesn't matter but it's
always nice to hear when someone's
favorite movie is kingpin maybe I'm
dating him I don't know Spencer's
evasive was very combative generally
seems very unpleasant I think either
essence or Spencer is single that's not
a final and I'm on the clock you know
I'm on the clock I'm getting rushed here
I know this is this is tough I just
don't want to get it wrong I just love
getting these things right but I think
Spencer is the single one
I was compost I guess you did great all
right you got me
no look I was I was afraid I was pretty
close when you put five people in front
of anybody and their whole point is to
lie their asses off and deke you out I
was still pretty close I mean I said
from the get-go I knew two of them were
dating right off the bat and I way it
came down to either essence or Spencer
and I made the wrong choice at the end
there there's a little bit of gut
instinct that you try and follow and
that sort of thing and I was wrong but
it happens
[Music]